julia and ludmila escaped the russian
bombardment of mariopol on march the
19th
over the next few days they risked their
lives three times driving back into the
city braving bullets shells and air
strikes in a desperate attempt to find
the father of their family 61 year old
alexander piliopenco
they fear
he never made it out
we were driving there were russians on
one side ukrainians on the other and
they were shooting says julia we were in
the middle it was terrifying but we were
determined to get dad
the family used to live near the azov
steel plant where an estimated 2
500 ukrainian soldiers and civilians
were trapped for weeks
as the fighting intensified they fled to
a basement under a block of flats in the
city centre
on the day they escaped the shelling was
intense and alexander never made it from
the basement to the waiting civilian car
we were sure he knew we would come back
for him says ludmilla
and he would wait for us in the basement
a few days later they returned to where
they had last seen
we
alexander
all the buildings were burnt and
destroyed says ludmilla and there was no
one there
ludmila and julia's story is not
uncommon the united nations estimates
that russia's invasion has forced more
than 12 million people to flee their
homes the ukrainian government says
thousands of them are searching for
friends and loved ones missing
feared dead
anna chazovnikova is a psychologist
volunteering at a center helping some of
the tens of thousands of people from
mariopol who fled to the ukrainian
controlled side
today i had a lady whose husband was
killed in front of her and she asked why
did i survive she like so many is deeply
disturbed constantly breaking down and
refusing to accept what has happened
families who come to this centre receive
food parcels once every two weeks
children play while their parents
register
and tell their stories to volunteers
andre used to work at the azov style
plant as a lathe operator he says he
left many friends behind
us
i think they are more sympathetic to the
occupiers they call me and ask when are
you coming back but i will never return
with russians in control
anastasia was a social worker in
mariopol before the war she struggles to
hold back her tears
we all lost friends they're gone forever
in my case it would have been death or
captivity because i refuse to work under
the occupiers i don't know if i will
ever see my city again
the ukrainian government accuses russia
of forcing tens of thousands of people
from mariopol into russia an accusation
russia denies
julia and ludmilla say their only hope
is that alexander is still alive
charles stratford al jazeera kiev